you mentioned something about the state
so what role let's talk about
companies governments parents
all the mechanisms that can be a source
of conditioning
which flavor of ice cream do you like
do you think the state is the right
thing for the future so governments that
are elected democratic systems
that are representing representative
democracy
is there some kind of political system
of governance that you find appealing is
it parents
meaning a very close-knit tribes of
conditioning that's the most essential
and then uh you and michael malus would
uh
happily agree that it's anarchy or the
state should be
dissolved or destroyed or burned to the
ground if you're michael malus
giggling um holding the torch
as the fire burns so which which is it
is the state
can the state be good or is the state
bad
for the condition of a beautiful world
a or b this is like an s you like tests
you like to give these uh simplified
good or bad things
um what i like the state
that we live in currently the united
states federal government to
stop existing today no i would really
not like that um
i think that would be not quite bad for
the world in a lot of ways
uh do i think that it's a
optimal social system and maximally uh
just inhumane and all those things and i
wanted to continue as is no
also not that um but i am much more
interested in it being able to evolve to
a better thing
without going through the catastrophe
phase that i think
it's just non-existence would give so
what size
of state is good in a sense like
do we should we as a human society as
this world becomes more globalized
should we be constantly striving to
reduce
the set you we can we can put on a map
like right now literally
like the the centers of power in the
world
some of them are tech companies some of
them are governments
should we be trying to as much as
possible decentralize
the power to where it's very difficult
to point on the map
the centers of power and that means
making a state however there's a bunch
of different ways to make the government
much smaller
that could be reducing
in the united states reducing the
the funding for the government all those
kinds of things their set of
responsibilities
the the set of powers it could be
i mean this is far out but making
more nations or maybe nations not in the
space that are
defined by geographic location but
rather in the space of ideas
which is what anarchy is about so
anarchy is about forming collectives
based on their set of ideas
and doing so dynamically not based on
where you were born and so on
i think we can say that the
natural state of humans if we want to
describe such a thing
was to live in tribes
that were below the dunbar number
meaning that for a few hundred thousand
years of human history
all of the groups of humans mostly
stayed under that size
and whenever we'd get up to that size it
would end up cleaving and so it seems
like there's a pretty strong
but there weren't individual humans out
in the wild doing really well right so
we were a group animal but with groups
that had a specific size so we could say
in a way humans were being domesticated
by those groups they were learning how
to have certain rules to participate
with the group
without which you get kicked out but
that that's still the wild state of
people and and maybe it's useful to do
as a side
statement which i've recently looked at
a bunch of papers around dunbar's number
where the mean is actually 150. if you
actually look at the original paper it's
a range it's really a range so it's
actually some somewhere under a thousand
so it's a range from like two to five
hundred or whatever it is but like you
could argue that the
uh i think it actually is exactly two uh
two the range is
two to five hundred and twenty something
like that and this is
the mean that's taken crudely it's not a
very good paper
the the in terms of the actual numerical
numerically speaking but it'd be
interesting if there's a bunch of dunbar
numbers that could be computed for
particular environments particular
conditions so on
it is very true that they're likely to
be something small
you know under a million but it'd be
interesting if we can expand that number
in interesting ways that will change the
fabric of this conversation i just want
to kind of throw that in there
i don't know the if the 150 is baked in
somehow in the heart
into the hardware we can talk about some
of the things that it probably has to do
with
up to a certain number of people
and this is going to be variable based
on the social technologies that mediate
it to some degree we can talk about that
in a minute um
up to a certain number of people
everybody can know everybody else pretty
intimately so let's go ahead and just
take 150
as a as an average number
everybody can know everyone intimately
enough that
if your actions made anyone else do
poorly it's your extended family and
you're stuck living with them
and you know who they are and there's no
anonymous people there's no just them
and over there
and that's one part of what leads to a
kind of tribal process where it's good
for the individual and good for the
whole has a coupling
also below that scale
everyone is somewhat aware of what
everybody else is doing there's not
groups that are very siloed and as a
result it's actually very hard to get
away with bad behavior
there's a forced kind of transparency
and so you don't need kind of like the
state
in in that way but lying to people
doesn't actually get you ahead
sociopathic behavior doesn't get you
ahead because it gets seen
and so there's a conditioning
environment where the
individuals behaving in a way that is
aligned with the interest of the tribe
is what gets conditioned when it gets to
be a much
larger system it becomes easier to
hide certain things from the group as a
whole as well as to be less emotionally
bound to a bunch of anonymous
people i would say there's also a
communication
protocol where up to about that number
of people
we could all sit around a tribal council
and be part of a conversation around a
really big decision do we migrate do we
not migrate do we you know some
something like that do we
get rid of this person and why why would
i want
to agree to be a part of a larger group
where everyone can't be part of that
council and so
i am going to now be subject to law that
i have no say in
if i could be part of a smaller group
that could still survive and i get a say
in the law that i'm subject to so i
think the cleaving
and a way we can look at it beyond the
dunbar number two is we can look at that
a civilization has
binding energy that is holding them
together and has cleaving energy and if
the binding energy exceeds the cleaving
energy that civilization will last
and so there are things that we can do
to decrease the cleaving energy within
the society things we can do to increase
the binding energy
i think naturally we saw that had
certain characteristics up to a certain
size kind of tribalism that
ended with a few things it ended with
people having migrated enough that
when you started to get resource wars it
you couldn't just migrate away easily
and so tribal warfare became more
obligated
it involved the plow in the beginning of
real economic surplus there were so
there were a few different kind of
um forcing functions
but we're talking about what size should
it be right what size should a society
be
and i think the idea like if we think
about your body for
a moment as a self-organizing complex
system that is multi-scaled
we think about bodies of wonderland our
body is a wonderland yeah
uh you have that's a john mayer song i
apologize
but yes so uh if you think about our our
body and the billions of cells that are
in it
well you don't have like think about how
ridiculous it would be to try to have
all the tens of trillions of cells in it
with no internal organization structure
right just like a sea of protoplasm your
democracy
and so you have cells and tissues
and then you have tissues and organs and
organs and organ systems and so you have
these layers of organization
and then obviously the individual and a
tribe in a
ecosystem and each of the higher layers
are both based on the lower layers but
also influencing them
i think the future of civilization will
be similar which is there's a level of
governance that happens at the level of
the individual
my own governance of my own choice
i think there's a level that happens at
the level of a family
we're making decisions together we're
inter-influencing each other and
affecting each other taking
responsibility
for the idea of an extended family and
you can see that like for a lot of human
history we had an extended family we had
a local community a local church or
whatever it was
we had these intermediate structures
whereas right now this kind of like the
individual
producer consumer taxpayer voter and the
massive nation state global complex
and not that much in the way of
intermediate structures that we relate
with and not that much in the way of
real personal dynamics all
impersonalized made fungible and
so i think that we have to have
global governance meaning i think we
have to have governance at the scale we
affect stuff and if
if anybody is messing up the oceans that
matters for everybody so that
that can't only be national or only
local
everyone is scared of the idea of global
governance because we think about some
top-down system of imposition that now
has no checks and balances on power i'm
scared of that same version so i'm not
talking about that kind of global
governance
it's why i'm even using the word
governance as a process rather than
government as an imposed
uh phenomena and so i think we have to
have global governance but i think we
also have to have local governance and
there has to be relationships between
them that each
where there are both checks and balances
and power flows of information
so i think governance at the level of
cities will be a bigger
deal in the future than governance at
the level of nation states because i
think
nation states are largely fictitious
things
that are defined by wars and agreements
to stop wars and like that i think
cities are
based on real things that will keep
being real where the proximity of
certain things together
the physical proximity of things
together gives increased value of those
things
so you look at like jeffrey west's work
on scale and finding that
companies and nation states and things
that have a kind of complicated
agreement structure get diminishing
return
of you of production per capita as the
total number of people increases beyond
about the tribal scale but the city
actually gets increasing productivity
per capita
but it's not designed it's kind of this
organic thing right
so there should be governance at the
level of cities because people can
sense and actually have some agency
there probably neighborhoods and smaller
scales within it and also verticals
and some of it won't be geographic it'll
be network-based right networks of
affinities
so i don't think the future is one type
of governance now what we can say
more broadly is say when we're talking
about groups of people that inter-affect
each other
the idea of a civilization is that we
can figure out how to coordinate our
choice making
to not be at war with each other and
hopefully increase total
productive capacity that's good for
everybody division of labor and
specialty so we all get
more better stuff and whatever but it's
a
it's a coordination of our choice making
i think we can look at civilizations
failing on the side
of not having enough coordination of
choice making so they fail on the side
of chaos and then they cleave and an
internal war comes about or whatever
or they can't make smart decisions and
they overuse their resources or whatever
or it can fail on the side of trying to
get order
via imposition via force and so it fails
on the side of oppression which ends up
being for a while functional
ish for the thing as a whole but
miserable for most people in it until it
fails
either because of revolt or because it
can't innovate enough or something like
that
and so there's this like toggling
between a
order via oppression and chaos and i
think the
idea of democracy not the way we've
implemented it but the idea of it
whether we're talking about
a representative democracy or a direct
digital democracy liquid democracy
republic or whatever the idea of an open
society participatory governance
is can we have order that is emergent
rather than imposed
so that we aren't stuck with chaos and
infighting and inability to coordinate
and we're also not stuck with oppression
and what would it take to have emergent
order
this is the most kind of central
question for me these days
because if
we look at what different nation states
are doing around the world and we see
nation states that are more
authoritarian that in some ways are
actually coordinating much more
effectively
so for instance we can see that
china has built high-speed rail not just
through its country but around the world
and the us hasn't built any high-speed
rail yet you can see that it brought 300
million people out of poverty in a time
where
we've had increasing economic inequality
happening
you can see like that
if there was a single country that could
make all of its own stuff if the global
supply chains failed
china would be the closest one to being
able to start to go closed
loop on fundamental things uh belt and
road
initiative supply chain on rare earth
metals
transistor manufacturing that was like
oh they're actually coordinating more
effectively in some important ways
in the last call it 30 years and
that's imposed order in post order and
we can see that if in the u.s
if no let's look at why real quick
we know why we created term limits so
that we wouldn't have
forever monarchs that's the thing we
were trying to get away from and that
there would be checks and balances on
power and that kind of thing
but that also has created a negative
second order effect which is nobody does
long-term planning
because somebody comes in who's got four
years they want re-elected
they don't do anything that doesn't
create a return within four years they
will end up getting them
elected re-elected and so the 30-year
industrial development to build
high-speed trains or
the new kind of fusion energy or
whatever it is just doesn't get invested
in
and then if you have left versus right
where whatever someone does for four
years then the other guy gets in and
undoes it for four years
and most of the energy goes into
campaigning against each other this
system is just dissipating as heat
right like it's just burning up as heat
and the system that has no term limits
and no internal friction in fighting
because they
got rid of those people can actually
coordinate better
but uh i would argue it has its own fail
states eventually
and dystopic properties that are not the
thing we want
so the goal is to accomplish to create a
system that does
long-term planning without the negative
effects of a monarch
or dictator that stays there for the
long term
and
accomplish that through uh not doing
the imposition of a single leader
but through uh emergent so that doesn't
that perhaps first of all the technology
in itself seems to me
maybe disagree allow for different
possibilities here
which is uh make primary the system not
the humans
so the the the basic uh the medium
on which the democracy happens like
like a platform or where people can uh
make decisions do the choice making
the coordination of the choice making
where emerges some kind of order to
where like something that applies at the
scale of the family
the extent family the city
the the country the the continent the
whole world
and then does that so dynamically
constantly changing based on the needs
of the people
sort of always evolving and it would all
be owned by google
you